Political and world wars don't happen by
accident,
done any more than poverty held us back
for them.
They are all curable.
They're all presented.
Uh,
no.
You know,
there are big interest being served by
these conflicts.
So it means standing up to the big
interest ad means mobilizing public
opinion at means the media playing a,
a crucially important role of
highlighting and informing and educating
people on his objective away as it's
possible.
But yes,
there can be an any given situation
there.
Con,
they adjust and a proper sacrament which
means compromise,
which means putting yourself and your
opponent's position.
Uh,
and you know,
if you want proof of that,
the proof does lie in Ireland to a
certain extent.
Here we have enp Islam and Martin
Mcguinness.
Cool,
cool.
Uh,
managing
partners and a power sharing
arrangement.
Uh,
we used to have the USSR,
no longer there.
We,
W we,
we used to have a cold war,
no longer there.
Uh,
there aren't any certainties once,
once shifts appear.
And I'm the things that I've learned and
I've,
I believe,
with grid conviction,
is that people who respond to the
political conditions in which they live.
So if you want to change our people to
respond or think changed their
conditions,
don't try to attack their core values
are.
I mean,
you can obviously have your own view of
it and you can argue the case.
But,
uh,
fundamentalism from whatever position I
think is,
is a sensory wrong EPA and somebody has
used to,
uh,
to inflect repression or injustice upon
other people.
So if you want to change our human
beings,
respond,
then changed the political conditions in
which they live.